the story of Hades and Persephone
is one of the most well known love
stories in Greek mythology and over the
years there have been a handful of
different variations Hades was known for
rarely ever leaving the underworld but
one of the few times he did venture
above-ground he came across Persephone
the daughter of Zeus and Demeter and he
fell instantly in love when Hades
consulted his brother Zeus who had
previously promised him a choice of his
daughters in marriage he accepted the
request of Hades but he knew that
Persephone's mother Demeter
would never allow her daughter to marry
the god of the underworld heartbroken at
the idea that he would never be with
Persephone
the two brothers came up with a plan
that would allow Hades to make Pasiphae
his wife
the next morning Demeter and her
daughter descended upon the earth and
Persephone was left with the nymphs of
the sea as her guides and Watchers while
her mother tended to the earth knowing
that the nymphs would never let
Persephone out of their sight for fear
of demitasse wrath Zeus had Gaia plant a
narcissus flower in a nearby garden
wandering into the garden alone
Persephone saw the narcissus flower and
was immediately drawn to its beauty when
she stooped down to pick the flower the
earth beneath her began to quake and a
gaping chasm soon appeared from that
chasm emerged Hades and his chariot of
black horses he grabbed Persephone
before she was able to scream for help
the nymph Sion had seen the abduction
and she attempted to rescue Persephone
but she was no match for Hades upon
seeing her friend descend deep into the
underworld she began to cry until she
melted into a pool of her own tears form
in the river Sion
when D'Amato returned her daughter was
nowhere to be found when she asked the
nihms that she had left to watch over
her daughter they had no answer furious
that they were unable to protect her
daughter she cursed them with plumed
bodies scaly feet and wings they would
now be called the sirens it was when the
river Sion washed up the bells of
Persephone
that them as I knew something dreadful
had happened to her daughter Demeter was
driven mad by her daughter's
disappearance she roamed the earth for
days on end searching and not fulfilling
her duties as goddess of the harvest and
fertility the earth began to dry
harvests began to fail plants withered
and animals died because of the lack of
food famine spread across the earth the
actions of dmitar resulted in untold
misery the cries of those suffering
could even be heard on Mount Olympus and
Zeus knew that if he did not stop
demitasse wrath humanity would disappear
he promised to bring Persephone back
from the underworld if it could be
proved that Hades was holding her
against her will during her time in the
underworld
Hades had beautiful gardens built for
Persephone and she was treated with
respect and compassion she saw a side to
Hades that no one else had seen before
and she began to fall in love with him
Hades had heard would Zeus proposed and
readied his chariot to return Persephone
but he was terrified that when given the
choice Persephone would not return to
him and so he gave her one last gift a
pomegranate
in Greek mythology it was believed that
if one ate the food given to them by
their captor they would always return to
that person
when Persephone was asked to where she
would like to live
she told Zeus and dmitar that she wished
to stay in the underworld with her
husband Demeter was infuriated with the
response and she was convinced that
Hades had somehow tricked her daughter
after a heated discussion Demeter made
it known that if her daughter did not
return she would never again make the
earth fertile Zeus decided that
Persephone would spend the portion of
the year with her husband Hades and the
rest of her mother on Olympus the
portion of time varies depending on the
story in some depictions Persephone
spent a third of the year in the
underworld and the rest on Mount Olympus
in other stories because Persephone ate
six pomegranate seeds she would then
spend six months of Hades and the rest
of the year of Demeter the arrangement
pleased neither Hades or Dimitar but
they were forced to accept it many
believe that the seasons of the year
could be explained by this story in the
six months that Persephone was not with
her mother the land was not fertile and
crops struggled to grow because in her
sadness demi-tour neglected her duties
these times of year became autumn and
winter when Demeter was reunited with
Persephone the land became fertile and
once again fruitful these months for
spring and summer thus creating the
cycle of seasons the death and rebirth
of nature
the story of Persephone in hades is one
that has divided people for years there
are those who believe that Hades was
somewhat of a villain in this story
taking Persephone against her will and
forcing her to live in the underworld
with him there are those who believe
Hades to have been a very misunderstood
character cold and unwilling to leave
the underworld but once he saw
Persephone he began to change and over
time she did fall in love with him
how do you guys feel about this story do
you feel Hades acted as a villain or in
the name of love do you think Persephone
would have returned to Hades if he did
not give her the pomegranate let me know
in the comments below as always I've
been your host mythology and fiction
explained
[Music]